hello my name is mark well time to FIFA
the game yeah I understand
gosh I see does I I feel I understand
who's out and Jay where are we a very
green eat on these cars [ __ ] help
I don't anyone play this [ __ ] [ __ ]
dare is hot tired a rock say your name
give the [ __ ] with Chris Pratt thinks it
stress nothing wrong oh crap mom who
gives a [ __ ] what Chris Pratt's mom's
motley Chris Pratt probably other fellas
are different if I can meet one
celebrity I think it's me oh yeah no
over exact Ephram yeah actually really
well I like Zack for his body like Zack
is the object and Pratt is the
personality yeah exactly
oh yeah they can be together in one body
obviously Zacks body I mean both like
Chris Pratt's got real good he did yeah
good he did so those are speak out so
what we're going to do it's not
traditionally played with three players
but we came up with the way that it
could be so what's gonna happen is these
two are going to go head to head I'm
going to do three turns of this thing
because I think it's a minute it's a
minute little sand timer here so I'm
gonna do three turns of this and they're
gonna try to get as many cards as I can
let's do to just cuz it's gonna be held
for me it sucks a lot this hurts really
badly this presses on the top of your
gums for something so what we're going
to do is we're going to set the timer
and then we're going to go for that and
then whoever because once I'm done then
he comes going to rotate in then Tyler's
going to rotate in eat everyone will
have two chances to guess what we are
saying whoever the most
at the end of the wind exact makes sense
cool all right
all right cool are you ready
aye aye captain I gotta thank you ah ah
your tongue you four or five guys ready
yeah
hey hey one or Oh hae young
morons people I hate my dog boring
people hate me young people make neon
yes
never question Martha never question
Martha rather the same time the half of
it
Randall lawyers were kept suit ahead
Lord we're handed the head up Lord wear
suits lawyers wear pant suits to bed yes
he told his mistress go Hawks
two poodles with magnificent Mohawk
telling you my brother is from my color
it is Mars you got it ah look here I was
going on Walker blood Bugs Bunny water
you got enough damn it broader by red no
harder my red is make it rub my head
with bacon order my red is agent brother
my head was makin uh order other utter
utter are not water order I already are
delighted kind of hot water I read it
would make it rough
everybody was making you got Lincoln why
can't you get water Iraq it's a shame
rudder my redwoods breaking no Haitian
butter my bread would make bacon yeah
see guys you can't steal a third got
their whole thing
oh thanks yo I'll go for mommy
Johnny applesauce you got it yes ray
they had all of the rich and famous
meaning has the rich and heinous Oh easy
pirates of the rich and pants aging
harlots of religion payment losing heart
waiting bathing habits of the rich in
pain
yeah you got it all right oh oh hi cut
free the bees are impossible I couldn't
get it you or guys we're getting is
bacon yeah way what was that one it was
butter my bread with bacon yeah you guys
were getting bacon just fine and I
didn't understand why you didn't get you
didn't connected by a knife and a t t it
sound like these because when you think
hunter [ __ ] I was going after just
fine
it's not three and a half to five and a
half I think
all right hind legs are popsicle
pancakes are sausages sticks high in
case our fantastic pancakes are hot so
cool okay so popsicle stick yes yes
three burrito one says free burrito in
big news I'll pitch high a lot hair-do
boiled fish flying water because noon
I'll hit play in your life your ball
fish playing water heat destroy you
super price compiled I tried Rex lava
Peter was playing the piano
something Pinker like performance
and Parvati Jana if you're performing in
white man I don't know mr. Garriga
[ __ ] Piper include a lazy bastard hi
paper into the wastebasket no I wrong
[ __ ] Piper into the main room
Tommy member in the waste bin what no I
cried on the phone I had that I got
nothing back that slide Jesus burrowing
in the backyard mmm he was burrowing in
the backyard hugs
cactus buzzes ah hog present practice
jumping rocks pogs pocket dusting loves
hugs practice jumping mouth hog practice
jumping log hogs practice gasping life
on the practice jousting long hug
practice Johnson
Oh hugs practice jumping rubber yeah
radhiya seguro
shaggy misses the rope Maggie misses the
Rope Maggie this is God good Maggie
misses we go ready
Maggie Maggie Maggie this is good ah
Maggie misanthrope
Maggie misses the boat yeah oh no car
yeah apart
oh my mouth hurts so much six five so
you're winning we're tied like no I've
gone through two I'm pretty much
guaranteed to lose a million unless I
sweep them are you ready
all right honey
a predator tank oh the [ __ ] thing
point one for me yes I can't declare
great heart balloon I can't cook a hot
balloon
I can't push we bought the light and
quickly hot balloons
I can't quickly pop balloons I I can't
cook a hot girl I can't hang behind the
balloons
I can't quickly hot balloons I can't
quickly
ha equally possible neither I hired our
new Nine Riders of the popcorn fired one
man named nine horrible popcorn and
mayonnaise nine riders of popcorn
McManus no neither of her corn nine
varieties of pepper horn man Wow my
grandma where my Venus whoa
the weatherman wishes for Ralph whoa the
weatherman wishes for the weather mail
wishes oh here broccoli tell me it's a
beautiful day on the east
it's a beautiful day on the beach it's a
beautiful day a beautiful day at the
beach what Laurie where picnic what's
the weather perfect Atlantic news why
were the perfect weather report for a
big block so I never pulled a picnic
while I was other for the picnic for the
picnic
hanging wire oh [ __ ] with snot oh no no
wrong
my nose is rotten my playful noses run
my playful notice but we all know rock
please not playful nose not all right
but not my playful nose nod not go la la
I love my words I will play with pliers
I know putting bratwurst in my eyes
homeward brothers problem are gone no
playful nose knock oh no lock baleful
things killed Batman
I like a playful cough and another guy
nah
hold on I'm you got what do you get this
one I don't propose to do that
what oh no rock playful nose rock - your
rock
playful nose got box labeled a playful
note spot - those bots playful knows
what man woof playful nose rock playful
nose talk label nose rock on playful no
Bop oh god yeah ah it was the inflection
of the throne is really hard to do Bob I
got five total on that turn on this turn
I got five so you have ten total there
were plenty of times where you guys were
just one word off he said gah
instead of a so I got 10 total what did
you get it's 9 9 and Tyler you got yes
I thought you got more to put a barrel I
didn't I win yay they're ones where you
basically gave him the answer and can
change for one word and I was like I
felt that giving it to him but he got
the one word right things you go oh okay
it's only fair hi so anyway that is
whatever the [ __ ] this game is called
so it is um fun it's entertaining is
that a saying yeah Beverly it's
entertaining so anyway so
Ethan's the winner yeah blaze and Ethan
ah second third
I suck it understanding gibberish I
would like it's just like whenever
there's beans and peas together it
wasn't very good no idea why all right
console this time actually a little bit
is that what we're supposed to be doing
actually look at the box
no it's down I lost gotcha no time
footage or console so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this one thank you eaten
entirely for being here with me uh hope
you got a lot of pictures out of that a
lot of gifts a lot of uh yeah I'll add
it to your collection I know you all
have a folder puppets kind of stuff so
up stop put it in there with that set so
good let us know if we had anything in
her teeth let us go over there if he
plays home oh what a video of it on the
internet we'll look at it so thanks
again everybody so much for watching you
can find their stuff in the linked in
the description below and as always we
will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]